l on retrouve en direct de méribel
michel charasse bonsoir bonsoir alors
que s'est il passé vous avez pris du
bronze en vous est dopé par la victoire
des douaniers
d'abord je pourrais être dopée par la
victoire des loyers parce que c'est
absolument magnifique et je suis très
fier d'être le chef de cette
administration a raison de mes fonctions
ministérielles et est très fier d'avoir
dans mon administration
ces garçons et ces filles qui sont pour
l'instant une partie de l'honneur de la
force alors pourquoi avez vous changé
d'avis michel charasse pour le reste
pour le reste qu'est ce qui s'est passé
ben tout simplement le bureau exécutif
du parti socialiste a accepté de
s'intéresser à ce qui se passait dans
une partie de la région d'auvergne et à
accepter de double a décidé plus
exactement de modifier la donne dans le
département de la haute loire puisque
c'était la raison pour laquelle j'avais
dit que je ne serai pas candidat parce
que la liste ne me convenait pas sur
deux ou trois points de détail le bureau
exécutif semble avoir remis les choses
dans le sens que je souhaitais et par
conséquent compte tenu des délais cool
et très bref depuis samedi dernier et
qui le jour où j'ai dit que je n'étais
pas candidat il n'y a plus d'obstacle à
ce que je veux quand déjà
mais pas le président qui vous l'a
demandé cette explication est le parrain
le président va pas demander
particulièrement le président s'occupe
pas de ce genre de choses
alors que je lui en ai parlé il m'a n'a
pas dissuadé particulièrement des
présidents il examine la situation comme
ça sur le plan global il s'intéresse pas
particulièrement à moi donc vous allez
affronter valéry giscard d'estaing de
quelle manière je veux pas affronter
valéry giscard d'estaing je vais
m'occuper de l'auvergne c'est à dire je
vais faire ce que monsieur giscard
d'estaing ne fait pas il est président
de la région d'auvergne depuis six ans
il vient jamais ou rarement il est
jamais là on peut pas le voir et l'étape
sort ici représentés moi je vais
m'occuper de l'auvergne cette région
souffrent et à des problèmes
elle a aussi des atouts importants
puisque mes amis et même au delà de mes
amis une grande partie des forces vives
de la région l'auvergne m'ont demandé
d'être candidat de façon très insistants
et ben on souhaite que je m'occupe de
l'auberge nous occuper de l'ovaire et
vous êtes prêt le lui dire dans un face
à face par exemple
tout ça c'est du cinéma mais non c'est
pas du tout les mains c'est un débat m'a
commandé main
marc comment vous n'accepterez pas qui
vous intéressent vous les journées c'est
du cinéma lancé le débat c'est le débat
à berne
et puisque les journalistes ont dit que
j'étais un dégonflé je ne leur donnerai
pas l'occasion de faire du cinéma
bon mais c'est pas un geste suicidaire
cinéma ou pas c'est pas un jeu
suicidaire je suis candidat pour gagner
et je vais essayer de gagner et je ferai
tout pour ça et j'éviterais de faire du
cinématographe pour faire plaisir aux
journalistes qui m'ont traité de
dégonfler bon parce qu'ils sont en panne
de copie et qui savent pas quoi écrire
bon mais s'il valéry giscard d'estaing
vous propose un face à face vous le
dites oui quand même
j'ai du cinéma à sa fin je vais me
promener dans toute l'auvergne
je vais aller dans la plupart des
collectivités des communes des cantons
d'auvergne a des tas d'endroits où
monsieur giscard d'estaing qui est
président de la région depuis six ans
jamais mis les pieds d'ailleurs j'espère
qu'il me suive ram qui dira qu'il faut
qu'ils fassent pareil ce qui nous
donnera l'occasion de visiter la région
de long qui très heureux ça contribuera
à son édification mais à sa connaissance
de la région merci ben voilà c'est tout
le reste du cinématographe je vais
m'occuper de l'eau faire merci merci
michel karam tout de même pour vous
comme pour les autres la route sera rude
tous les sondages que nous publions
chaque jour depuis le début de la
semaine